they can help you that's the village is
this the Village Voice yes yes I would
like to place a personal ad what would
you say in Iraq I I like to say I'm
well-endowed player well-endowed
of course 31 Sikhs dirty hold a sip
Christou repeat that seeks dirty hole to
sit down and have her as so uh dirty
[Music]
Chris damn and have as teared up oh yeah
this is straight hip-hop its how females
in hip-hop like it they like to be told
ape this I would communicate um
babies got to keep it real than a mofo
as I roll up deep in her stays keeping
her stays well crevice serious inquiries
only ok this pad cannot go under the men
seeking women category and you'd have to
change your wording you can't we
couldn't saying deep into her crevice
what can I say how about this I have
something totally different in it
totally different at um dear his old
which I don't know know his old no hole
instead of his olds can I put Liz
eighties baby was on still get cheesy
with the nizzy Lizzy get busy me a
sizzle since is early just Azores
no why not I think that's flour okay
let's keep it simple then only only
hotties need apply must like long walks
on the beach nice in front of the
fireplace in sushi
shouldn't steal my stuff I like my women
Harry
must have titties in the badonkadonk but
now I'm like dirty ass got to have a
clean ass you obviously have you read
our personal yeah
I'm just putting my person who this what
I want and and the last but not least
gotta have strong legs especially at the
knees gonna spend a lot of time on the
knees you cannot place a graphic ad what
about the danke don't but no you can't
put badonkadonk
what about must have back back
must have back what tonight don't steal
my stuff and then after that I like them
hairy as hell could you just read that
back to me
do you have only hotties need applying
mm-hmm got to have strong legs
mm-hmm must have back don't steal my
stuff mm-hmm I like a lot of hair
everywhere
nice nice nice oh one more thing I like
stretch marks you must have a c-section
scar on your green you can't bet in
print oh one more thing then
gotta love to hump now look I got got a
love to bone nope you know the C ring is
no that's not going you're at either
must buy me a can I buy you anything in
your ad no what about this I want to
bust a double horizontal on your ass no
okay okay take care I'll let you show
okay I love you I love you change no
don't change don't change don't you girl
meets every night can I meet you
black you know baby can I meet you
sounds sexy